house compresses and welcome to new
series that I like to call creating porn
no wait creating fan fictions that's it
but now it's time to sculpture some
fanfiction first suggestion is Patrick
and speech babe all right we got the
legs going
very sexy let's do the arms it looks
like something else but it's not what
you think it is is his arms stopped
looking like a penis god damn you speech
being damn spongebob is packing man
Jesus oh my god those eyes they look
like a badminton balls all right
let's focus here we have a mission oh my
god
what have I done now this is a
fanfiction so there's gonna be some
lovemaking involved so I was thinking
I'll make Patrick underneath him I have
no [ __ ] clue if this is gonna work
not working very well so far
don't worry about it right nightmares it
might look like he has a tumor right now
but that's that's not what we're looking
at it looks like he's missing a baby
Oh God Oh God
spongebob what happened what are you
doing wait what did you do to Patrick
all right [ __ ] it let's color it then
this is the greatest fan fiction of all
time look at that that's sweet spongebob
ass all right where's Patrick's face my
favorite fan fiction the did SpongeBob
and Patrick is making love what are you
what are you breasts a I think it's
pretty high
too hot for you too I guess we'll see
next fanfiction next to Justin is Taylor
Swift and a big toe Taylor Swift which
model should we start with the owl the
dog the man it's kind of sexist though
there doesn't have a woman but no
problem Taylor Swift we can we can fix
that for you just need just suck up the
Bulge there it is this is this is really
disturbing I'm so sorry
that's quite a chest isn't it Taylor and
I didn't know till the Zeus was pregnant
on her chest that's that's also great
face needs to be a little smaller I
don't know what's going on for this
program man oh my god I'm sorry Taylor
I'm trying to make her beautiful it
doesn't work let's oh god what Taylor no
that's beautiful Taylor and a pancake
the greatest fanfiction known to man
oh it's um max strings that's why okay
don't worry we can save this something
awful happened here
Oh God I mean it still doesn't look like
Taylor Swift but at least at least no
one has died yet Taylor Swift is my best
friend I want her to look snazzy at
least so outside how does that look
yes yes Taylor yes yes yes yes oh my God
look at that face
it looks like my next mistake okay well
let's give her some clothing because she
can't be nude damn that that's big
that's a bit over exaggerated dammit
alright some of us said the ship was her
toes so let's let's make that happen
welcome to my channel by the way if it's
this first video you're watching this is
doesn't get any better than that her toe
it looks kind of like a slipper but it
is a toe don't worry about it
that's my tailor right there my best
friend dam Taylor you look good Taylor
Oh Taylor Taylor Swift there it is
damn it where somewhere is it somewhere
there it is the Taylor Swift in tow
probably the greatest fan fiction ever
known to man beautiful
let's save it and my mother to the next
one ah here's a great one Adele and
Satan yeah it's my favorite chips don't
worry about what I'm doing right now
it's all gonna make sense in just a
second well this is Satan and something
alright I don't I don't think my plan is
really working out that way is it sad
that I'm actually genuinely trying here
and this is the results don't worry
about it I think you understand what I'm
going though
oh don't you worry don't you worry child
all right we got Satan now time for
Adele Stas of your love remind me real
lives not kill kill thinking that Adele
money you know yes yes yes this is it
the latest fan fiction well there is
absolutely something satanic about it
I'll get you gotta give me that let's
let's keep coloring there it is
Adele and Satan yes the greatest
sculptures ship of all time what the
[ __ ] have I done I feel like that was so
bad that I have to do another one so
let's see what else we got all right
I found one it's Justin Bieber and
Jensen's ankles that looks great
looks so good they drew a farm of
Justine oh I just realized his name is
Jen Jensen Ackles I thought I was gonna
put his ankles oh my god this ruins
everything
ankles let's go with that anyway yes I'm
feeling it got a revetment you feeling
it all right so let's make him with his
ankles into Jensen from Supernatural
this should be pretty easy considering
I'm an expert you don't look so happy
Dean what's the matter Dean huh
what's the matter you don't like you
don't like my heart daddy Justin Bieber
and his ankles there it is
thank you I want to thank all my fans
for supporting me throughout the years
because of what I do it really means a
lot
oh god I'm scared I'm scared I'm too
scared to keep going
thank you for watching I'll see you bros
in the next one stay awesome so you look
like they stripped down a lot of things
which might make sense I mean they do
that since up - I'm still very confused
it's just a lot to take in at once
because you were kind of used to do